South Bend Indiana was also the target
of mother nature's fury when a tornado
touched down there more than a dozen
states in the central and eastern US
start the day under a severe weather
threat a tornado slammed South Bend and
other parts of Indiana over the weekend
Adriana Diaz is in South Bend outside
the day care facility that was nearly
destroyed Adriana was anybody hurt well
Anthony good morning fortunately the
tornado hit this daycare center on a
Sunday when no one was inside but as you
can see half of the building is
completely destroyed this is the closest
we're going to get because of these
downed power lines now this building
bore the brunt of the tornado as it
moved through here but most of the area
was actually spared the National Weather
Service will be here later today to
assess the damage the tornado was caught
on camera as it moved near a CVS
Pharmacy just after 8:00 p.m. last night
you can see pieces of debris in the air
and moments after it hit the storm was
so strong it downed trees and knocked
out power there were no reports of any
major injuries that same storm system
also brought flash flooding to parts of
Missouri in southwest Missouri roads
washed out buildings were damaged and
there were reports of multiple water
rescues now forecasters say the risk of
the severe weather continues today here
in Indiana but primarily wind damage
there's a low likelihood of more
tornadoes gale
all right Adriana thank you very much